et on a dit et effectivement il ya de
nombreux travaux pénibles physiquement
mais parce qu'on a eu un travail pénible
alors la seule solution c'est de partir
plus tôt c'est tout on ne se préoccupe
pas de la prévention on ne se préoccupe
pas des conditions de travail nous
souhaitons un système universel
c'est le premier point et nous
développons pour tous les travailleurs
tous les travailleurs
la pénibilité ça c'est le premier point
est le deuxième point c'est que nous
mettons en place une évaluation à 55 ans
des conditions de travail via la situer
la branche la tmp pour pouvoir réviser
réviser les conditions de travail et
avoir de la prévention alors je vous
dirais une chose je préfère être un
playmobil du 21e siècle un soldat de
plomb du 19e mais un maximum chez benoît
ces baignoires merci merci madame la
présidente
au nom des députés du groupe id y agir
indépendant moi je souhaite exprimer
bien notre désapprobation par rapport à
l'amendement 23 971 et les
sous-amendement pourquoi l'amendement
propose la nation garantit que les
réformes des retraites ne conduisent pas
une régression
moi je souhaite que dans ce nouveau
projet de réforme des retraites
celles et ceux des français qui ont de
bons revenus et notamment dont le revenu
dépasse de plusieurs fois le plafond
annuel de la sécurité sociale
je souhaite que ces et ceux des français
qui bénéficient de retraites chapeaux
fasse des efforts en faveur des français
de condition modeste
j'ai pas si ce sera une régression pour
eux mais je souhaite qu'ils fournissent
des efforts premier point le deuxième
point la pénibilité
plusieurs députés à juste titre se sont
exprimés sur la pénibilité est en effet
dans certains métiers de l'industrie
certains métiers de l'agroalimentaire
certain métier de soignant certains
métiers du bâtiment des travaux publics
certains métiers de la grande
distribution sont difficiles le texte
prévoit le cas des postures pénibles les
vibrations mécaniques les charges
lourdes et les risques chimiques
il prévoit de prendre en compte ces
considérations c'est là l'objet de
l'article 32 que nous n'avons pas pu
examiner en commission
je ne sais pas si nous pourrons
l'examiner ici moi je souhaiterais que
quand on va évoquer la pénibilité on
aborde aussi les horaires décalés les
horaires de nuit et les cadences
imposées par les robots sur les lignes
de production mecs l'objet de l'article
l madame pires bonne merci madame la
présidente
alors c'est vrai que on donne peut-être
parfois l'impression de débats
brouillant depuis trois jours mais j'ai
envie de dire ça l'image du texte
finalement comment pour ailleurs en être
utile autrement
alors monsieur le ministre je suis
intervenu une seule fois depuis trois
jours j'ai posé une seule question elle
concernait la retraite des aides
soignants et des infirmières et je suis
désolé elles font partie là des
carrières actives elles ont elles
peuvent portières aujourd'hui à 57 ans
je n'ai pas eu de réponse est pour moi
demain elles auront une retraite
dégrader alors question supplémentaire
vous avez tout à l'heure évoqué les
tiers-temps la question et précises
liées tiers-temps ouvre droit au minimum
contributif c'est ce que vous nous avez
dit pouvez vous nous préciser si ce
minimum contributif sera proratisé ou
non et puisque comme beaucoup se
plaignent de ne pas avoir de réponses à
leurs questions je vais vous poser des
questions mais ce sera pas les miennes
ce sera celle d'un courrier du 11
février 2020 au premier ministre de
monsieur laurent saint martin et
d'émilie cariou elles sont précis ces
questions comme ce n'est pas laid comme
ce ne sont pas les nôtres
peut-être aurez-vous des réponses et
elle concerne les indépendants et les
libéraux dont elles sont bien raccrocher
à l'amendement de monsieur vélo les
indépendants et libéraux seront soumis à
de fortes hausses de cotisations à
l'initiative du gouvernement la
commission spéciale adopté un amendement
précisant l'habilitation donnée au
gouvernement de légiférer par
ordonnances pour revoir l'assiette de
cotisations des travailleurs
indépendants il prévoit un abattement de
30 % dans la limite d'un an tan tenant
compte des cotisations sociales dues
trois questions quels sont les montants
annuels de perte de cotisations et
contributions sociales 1 milliard un
milliard sept points d'interrogation
comment sera financé la réduction de ses
recettes
les autres branches de la sécurité
sociale vont elles voir leurs ressources
baissé comment la transition va se
passer pouvez-vous chiffré par exercice
budgétaire les transferts de charges qui
sont envisagées beaucoup de questions on
attend les réponses si madame la députée
monsieur dharréville dernier orateur pu
monsieur le ministre est en passe au
vote
merci madame la plus enjouée m'astreins
à trois remarques parce que il est
évident madame qui restent bonnes vient
de le dire que si le débat prendre cette
tournure c'est aussi à cause de la
nature du texte tel qu'il est rédigé et
vous devez donc évidemment à assumer
cela première chose notre notre collègue
benoit a évoqué les retraites chapeaux
nous
demande que ça que les retraites chapeau
sont intégrés dans le dispositif à ma
connaissance pour l'instant ça n'est pas
le cas mais si on peut se retrouver sur
le sujet ce sera volontiers
deuxième élément
notre collègue ou rosicky a opposé de
manière un peu grossière la prévention
et la réparation
il ya besoin de prévention et nous
l'avons dit nous nous battons pour ça il
est très bien placé pour savoir que
c'est mon cas puisque nous avons rendu
le rapport ensemble sur le sujet mon
cher collègue mais ensuite que nous
avons besoin aussi de la réparation
parce qu'au stade où nous en sommes un
certain nombre de femmes et d'hommes ont
aussi vu leur vie abîmer leur santé
abîmé et il faut donc en tenir compte
quoi qu'il en soit et ça n'est en aucun
cas un renoncement mais une juste mesure
troisième remarque et je m'en tiendrai
là monsieur le ministre on vous a
demandé des renseignements sur le
rendement des cotisations et vous nous
répondez sur le rendement du point ce
n'est pas tout à fait la même chose
déjà première remarque deuxièmement vous
nous dites le taux de 5,5 pour le
rendement du point est garanti je ne les
vues nulle part dans le texte on a vu
quelques intentions affichées de sa de
là mais on n'a pas vu cette réalité est
gravé dans votre texte donc j'en profite
pour vous demander confirmation sur le
sujet 3e troisième chose monsieur le
ministre vous nous dites que la valeur
d'achat et la valeur service du point
soit indexée de la même façon je ne vois
pas où c'est écrit merci monsieur
l'arrivée alors monsieur le ministre il
faut il faut que nous terminions
impérativement avant 13h30 parce que
sinon ça reporteraient leurs deux
reprises et je ne veux pas le faire donc
je vous invite à faire une réponse brève
ou à défaut si vous le voulez parce que
vous beaucoup de questions vous ont été
posées à la reprise vous aurez tout
loisir si vous le souhaitez de pouvoir
vous exprimer plus longuement tout à
fait écoutez je vous propose qu'on fasse
comme ça et faire un petit accusé de
réception simplement au député eric
coquerel parce que j'avais préparé
effectivement une réponse à une question
qui m'avait posé hier soir et il a tout
à fait raison de souligner que je n'ai
pas eu l'occasion de le faire à ma
décharge si on doit regarder aussi à ma
décharge il y avait de nombreuses
interventions et hier soir et c'était un
peu compliqué de me remettre au musée
tout ça mais je je sais près et on en
prend tout à l'heure très bien merci de
votre compréhension monsieur le millier
alors je vais appeler les
sous-amendement certains sont à main
levée d'autres en scrutin public donc le
41 1855 tous ont reçu un avis négatif de
la commission et du gouvernement
à main levée celui ci qui est pour et
qui est contre il n'est pas adopté le 42
1229 de madame hautain qui est pour et
qui est contre il n'est pas adopté le
41e 1862 monsieur jumelles qui est pour
et qui est contre il n'est pas adopté le
41 1858 de monsieur dharréville qui est
pour et qui est contre il n'est pas
adopté le 42 1206 scrutin public le
scrutin est ouvert de madame rubin le
scrutin co voici le résultat du scrutin
votants 103 exprimé 95 majorité 48 pour
15 contre 81 l'assemblée n'a pas adopté
le 41 1863 de lesieu jumelles qui est
pour et qui est contre il n'est pas
adopté le 41 1869 le scrutin est ouvert
de monsieur dharréville le scrutin est
clos
voici le résultat du scrutin votants
sans exprimer 103 majorité 52 pour 19
contre 84 l'assemblée n'a pas adopté le
41 1864 de monsieur dharréville qui et
pour qui et contre il n'est pas adopté
le 41 1867 de monsieur jumelles qui est
pour et qui est contre il n'est pas
adopté le 41 1873 de monsieur jumelles
qui est pour et qui est contre il n'est
pas adopté le 42 1246 de monsieur k
tenant ce qui est pour et qui est contre
il n'est pas adopté le 41 1876 de
monsieur d'arrivée
qui est pour et qui est contre il n'est
pas adopté le 41 1879 de monsieur
jumelles qui et pour qui et contre il
n'est pas adopté le cas renter à 1883 de
monsieur jumelles qui est pour et qui
est contre il n'est pas adopté le 42
1198 de monsieur corbières qui et pour
qui et contre n'est pas adopté le 41
1885 de monsieur dharréville qui est
pour et qui est contre il n'est pas
adopté le 41 1886 scrutin public le
scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat votants 108 exprimer
sans majorité 51 pour 18 contre 83
l'assemblée n'a pas adopté le 42 milles
203 scrutin public de monsieur coquerel
le scrutin est ouvert le scrutin est
clos
voici le résultat du scrutin votants 104
exprimé 81,18 majorité cinq ans pour 15
contre 83 l'assemblée n'a pas adopté le
42 1164 de monsieur le fur le scrutin
est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin votants
sans exprimer 110 majorité 56 pour 27
contre 83 l'assemblée n'a pas adopté le
41 1888 de monsieur jumelles le scrutin
est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin votants 108
exprimé 102 majorité 52 pour 19 contre
83 l'assemblée n'a pas adopté le 41 1893
de monsieur jumelles le scrutin est
ouvert
à moi il est un des mois il est indiqué
ah oui pardon à main levée à malause et
donc de monsieur jumelles qui est pour
et qui est contre il n'est pas adopté le
41 1897 de monsieur dharréville kippour
qui est contre il n'est pas adopté le 41
1901 de monsieur jumelles qui est pour
et qui est contre il n'est pas adopté le
42 1193 à un scrutin public le scrutin
est ouvert de monsieur catane ans
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin vote en ce
sens est exprimée 106 majorité 54 pour
23 contre 83 l'assemblée n'a pas adopté
le 42 1073 de monsieur le fur qui est
pour et qui est contre il n'est pas
adoptée scrutin public sur l'amendement
qui n'a pas été souvent des amendements
de monsieur vélo ayant reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos voici le résultat du
scrutin votants 109 exprimer sans cette
majorité 54 pour 24 contre 83
l'assemblée n'a pas adopté prochaine
séance cet après midi à 15 heures suite
du projet de loi instituant un système
universel de retraite
la séance est levée
oh
[Musique]
c'était manifestement une
mésinterprétation de sa part parce que
je ne veux pas croire que ce soit
simplement le désir obscur de brider le
débat parlementaire et droit
d'amendement merci monsieur vers la
séance est ouverte
l'ordre du jour appelle la suite du
projet de loi instituant